[Music]
hi everyone Thanks for attending this
session so today I would like to talk to
you about how to provision hardware for
running ml experiments in a better
manner on gcp and also just to get an
idea of my audience how many of you are
into ml with gcp using gcp for ML stuff
okay fair mix seems like a fair mix and
how many of you are using vertex AI for
this purpose
anymore cool
ah I forgot to take my slide Ginger
sorry about it but that's okay
all right
here's a bit about myself I'm an
incoming developer Advocate at a company
called hugging face previously I was at
an Australian startup called cut it
there I used to deal with a lot of text
and HTML data so that's about me
so also just as a disclaimer this is not
my soul work I am presenting this work
on behalf of my ex colleagues Nila bro
and Shane and of course myself
and here's a rough agenda of what's
about to come we will start off by
discussing the traditional and the
typical workflow of provisioning uh you
know instances for running ml
experiments and then we'll try to
dissect the problems uh typically
involved in such a workflow and then
we'll get to the meat of the talk where
we will sort of discuss how we can
better streamline this workflow with
something called terraform and then
we'll conclude with a demo yeah
so let's start with the standard
workflow
and as with most of the other services
on gcp vertex AI you know provides you
with a graphical user interface that is
sort of that sort of follows a point and
click kind of a workflow but before we
go to the vertex AI part let's quickly
discuss the main components of you know
running nml experiment so you would want
a pre-configured environment where you
have all the dependencies and the Kuda
stuff sorted out then you will probably
want a notebook instance for better
engagement and interactivity across the
different modules and then you'll
probably need access to tpus and gpus if
you are into running you know compute
intensive stuff and optionally you would
also want a you know Central Storage
bucket to sort of serialize your
experimentation artifacts
and vertex AI workbench instance which
is a managed service provided by Google
slot platform lets you provision a
notebook instance just with a few clicks
it offers you with a graphical user
interface and it comes with most of the
things already configured so as you can
see on the you know screenshots here you
just select and specify a few things and
boom you are up and running just within
a two or three minutes
and similarly if you also want to
provision a Google Cloud Storage bucket
then also it again involves it consists
of a few clicks it's just that
now this is pretty straightforward right
now you might be wondering what could be
problematic in this straightforward
workflow now let's try to dissect it
now the problem here is in repeatability
and you know lack of reusability every
time you try to create a new instance
the same steps are being you know
repeated and what if you miss out on a
particular step now in for our case we
are just trying to provision a notebook
instance and a bucket on GCS what if
there are other resources that you want
to provision for running your ml
experiments right it's easy to miss out
a particular step and this also has a
direct impact on the resource cleanup
side right what if you forget to clean
one resources which can you know and you
forget to clean that one resource up and
you are basically doomed for life it can
lead to unnecessary costs and all that
so basically the point I'm trying to
make here is this typical workflow the
point and click workflow does not give
you any reusability it does not enforce
any Version Control or whatever there
has to be a better way right
and now I am going to sort of
shamelessly read out a code from
terraform it says
provisioning infrastructure through
point and click graphical user
interfaces or custom scripts is slow
error from inefficient and does not
scale basically it sums up it sums up
everything that I wanted to say about
the point and click workflow that is
typically used for Hardware provisioning
so yeah
now additionally uh you also might you
know uh you also might need to install
custom python dependency and also custom
system level packages Additionally you
also might need metadata scripts or
startup scripts uh to you know better
control your notebook instances
now I really hope I could convince you
why point and click way of you know
provisioning Hardware isn't the most
suitable way when you are especially
working in a distributed team
uh yeah cool so with that in mind let me
introduce uh terraform to you and how it
can help us tackle some of the
challenges again a Shameless readout
I'll keep this slide on for about 20
seconds just so you can read it
say to sort of the long story cut short
here is terraform helps you to provision
and treat you know infrastructure as a
code so that you can eliminate any
redundancy any repeatability across the
different steps that might be needed to
provision Hardware effectively and
reliably
cool so with terraform you are going to
realize the same exact steps involved in
your workflow but with code and the code
will include defining a set of variables
such as resource names GPU types machine
types and so on and specification of
what resources uh you wish to sort of
provision on Google Cloud
and optionally you can also you know add
a startup script to your notebook
instance resource we'll get to that in a
moment
now let's start with the basic structure
of your you know terraform code it's you
start by defining all your you know
Hardware related variables in a script
called variables.tf and TF stands for
the terraform extension and then you
specify what resources are going to be
provisioned in a script called main.tf
you can name the scripts in any way you
want but naming certain things in a
certain way I think helps you achieve a
sense of you know idiomaticness and also
a structure and optionally if you have
any scripts metadata scripts or startup
scripts you can keep them under a
directory called scripts and then you
can also use those scripts inside from
the main.tf scripts
all right now here's how you know the
the here's how you could put all the
content inside the variables.tf script
you would start by defining all your gcp
related stuff the project name the
region and also the zone and then with
and the rest of the steps basically
depend on the kind of resources that you
want to provision in our case it's just
a notebook instance and a bucket on gcp
and the code for all this by the way
look much simpler than you may think
so yeah the usual gcp stuff uh let's
start with the variables.tf script it's
the usual gcp stuff the project ID the
location and the region
and then you have got your notebook
instance you start by defining the
notebook's name the machine type GPU
type and all that
and then again a couple of GCS related
stuff and as you can see it has a it it
has got a nice sequence so you start by
defining the general gcp related stuff
then you get to all the resources that
you want to provision again in our case
we have got a notebook instance and also
a GCS bucket
now within the main file uh you
basically start by specifying what
resources you are going to follow what
resources you are gonna provision so we
start by start with the usual gcp stuff
as usual and then we get to the notebook
part where we Define machine type
location gpus and all that
and then we get to the specifics of the
notebook instance for example the kind
of GPU that we want to use uh how many
GPU accelerators that we want to use and
so on and of course for brevity I've cut
down some parts but I hope you
understand
and then uh yeah and other things might
include whether or not we are interested
in installing the GPU drivers of course
we are interested in installing the GPU
drivers no one wants to sort of sort out
the Kuda stuff on their own at least I
do not know of any and then we can
specify what's the boot disk size what's
the data disk size and so on
and as usual as usual we conclude with
the GCS related stuff and as I was
mentioning for brevity I have I have cut
down certain part parts like sub Network
networks and so on
and here you can also specify a couple
of additional things as I was mentioning
uh at the beginning like startup scripts
or metadata scripts so I like to really
you know control uh the CPU utilization
of my instances specifically I want a
script that can monitor my CPU
utilization over a period of time and if
it falls below a certain threshold it
will just basically automatically shut
down uh The Notebook instance that can
save me a ton of money right but if you
have got a custom you know Docker
container which you would like to mount
in your notebook instance then it's also
sort of possible you just need to
specify the container image resource
within your main.tf terraform script
cool
they told me I have got only 15 minutes
left which is fine and if you are
working in a distributed and remote team
you can optionally store the you know
intermediate terraform scripts which
enforces uh you know better concurrency
and better collaboration
cool
now before we get to the demo part let's
tackle this elephant let's get to this
uh comparison why are we not using shell
scripts for uh this purpose that's
because shell scripts do not understand
the state and with terraform you get a
sense of states right because it
understands what resources have been
successfully provisioned and what
resources got failed during the
provision stage and it also gives you a
better control
over the entire life cycle of your
infrastructure management workflow and
of course since we are doing things
using Code basis Version Control comes
by default with that
cool let's get to the demo part can we
have the screen for demo
can we have the screen for demo it's
there cool thank you
so what I'm gonna do here is I'm gonna
clone the accompanying repository for
this talk by the way I'm gonna share uh
the resources just after my tokens so
don't worry about it I'm gonna clone the
accompanying Repository
all right it's cloned I'm gonna navigate
to the directory
I'm gonna use my favorite code Editor to
open the directory which is vs code
so I guess we are already here oh all
right
cool I'm gonna navigate to the terraform
directory I'm gonna open the vars.tf
file I'm gonna zoom in a bit okay we can
see everything I'm gonna change my gcp
project name fast AI
exploration it's a very childish name I
know uh which is okay I'm gonna rename
my notebook instance name
and also the GCS bucket name
so let me quickly walk you through the
script so that you have an understanding
so we are basically starting off with
the usual gcp stuff all the variables
that are needed to sort of provision
your Hardware resources effectively then
we are getting to the notebook instance
part where we are basically specifying
the GPU type the GPU account what image
family to use and what not and then we
are finally concluding with the GCS
related stuff and yeah I mean we need to
also specify which network and which sub
network to use but we can skip that part
for now
now that's all that we need to know of
by the way if you have already sort of
configured the gcp authentication and
authorization locally or any or on any
other environment you can directly clone
this repository and get started provided
you have got all the services and the
apis enabled
let me switch back to my terminal
navigate to the terraform directory
run terraform init
terraform has been successfully
initialized terraform plan
so it's calculating what resources it's
gonna provision so as we can see it's
gonna add or provision two resources
which is a notebook instance and a
bucket on Google Cloud Storage now
that's done we can actually start the
provisioning workflow so terraform apply
Auto
approve
and as you might already know uh
provisioning or spinning up a bucket
instance on GCS it's not that time
consuming but you know spinning up
notebook instances or you know virtual
machine instances that that have got
gpus and all the other custom
dependencies they take time so while
that's shocking up what I have done here
is I have created a notebook instance
using following the same workflow so
that we can quickly skip to the demo
part
and yeah you just need to take my vote
for it because I have actually done that
so ml hyphen NB is The Notebook that has
I had provisioned using the same
workflow so after our notebook instance
has been provisioned we would want to
validate a couple of things right for
example whether or not the Cuda stuff is
already sorted out for us whether the
custom Convoy announcement that we
wanted the startup script to you know
create for us whether that got created
or not and also uh the CPU utilization
stuff right I forgot to show you the
startup script that I have also attached
to the notebook instance let me quickly
show show that
so I am also attaching this particular
startup script to The Notebook instance
which by the way you can also do from
the graphical user interface it's
basically creating a conda custom
content environment with python 3.8 it's
also configure a bunch of configuring a
bunch of git stuff and then we are
getting to the CPU utilization part
where uh where it will automatically you
know turn off uh the instance if the CPU
utilization goes below a certain
threshold so that's all about the
startup script
and here's a brief rundown of the
main.tf file where we are basically
inheriting all the values from our
variables.tf file and we are just
specifying how the resources uh should
be provisioned and what resources
exactly should be provisioned so that's
it
and I'll let it load
I just we just need to wait for the
notebook to get successfully switched on
so that's that
and meanwhile Let me refresh the GCS
bucket console
this is the bucket that I had instructed
terraform to create for me just now so
that has been successfully created
let's see what's going on here
I have got okay eight minutes
yeah gcp folks maybe you want to improve
the you know Hardware switch on timing
so it's kind of slow it gets frustrating
at point in times so we are just we just
need to sort of wait
to again just to give you another
context after your Hardware resource in
our case which is a notebook instance
has been successfully provisioned you
would want to sort of validate and
verify a couple of things like which uh
showed in the
startup script we had asked terraform to
you know create a custom uh conda
environment for us with python 3.8 we
would want to verify it of course the
Cuda stuff whether or not it has been
sorted out for us and then the CPU
utilization part so for that we are
going to use the serial output of the
notebook instance that that is just
about to be just just about to get
provisioned so these are the things that
we are going to validate so
not sure why it has not been switched on
yet
okay
okay
it's switched on
cool
again we'll have to wait for a while
I think not more than two three minutes
cool
all right
stairs
so the first comment that I'm gonna run
here is NVIDIA SMI to check
if the Cuda stuff is sorted out
all right we can access the GPU and Cuda
seems to be doing just fine
and then conda EnV list the custom conda
environment which is pi 38 which is
exactly what we had specified in the
startup script
so Pi 38 that's there and then we also
need to check the serial outputs uh to
know if the CPU utilization stuff is
working as we had expected I'm gonna
also copy The Notebook instance name
yes I meant that
all right cool let me do it once again
all right it's taking time to reload but
that's fine I'm gonna just keep doing it
I've got five minutes of time so that's
fine
uh one more I guess
I'm gonna copy it
oh I guess it got shut down
automatically
is it
no it's there
okay let me refresh it once again
oh
oh cool it's there
yeah so probably the startup script is
taking time to sort of get reflected but
here in somewhere down the serial logs
you will see uh the total CPU
utilization that has been you know
captured by the startup script so yeah
it take it usually takes a bit of time
to get reflected but yeah you get the
idea let me try it for one last time
oh okay now we can see
so the machine is already in use
resetting counter to zero and the idle
minutes count is zero so we have got uh
we have got successful validation now
can we get back to the slides please
all right so just to wrap up my session
we we sort of took a short look into why
the point and click workflow of you know
provisioning Hardware is bad business
especially when you are running ml
experiments at scale and also in a
distributed team Manner and how we can
you know improve that workflow by using
the right set of tools in a codified
manner
and thanks for being such a great
audience and I would like to leave you
with a short link in case you want to
refer to the materials that I presented
today it includes the slides it includes
the code and also a short demo in case
you need to refer to it and thank you
[Music]